The birth rate for twins is going up!
And in related news, my desire to have children
has plummeted.
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and if you've
been on the internet at all the past couple
days, then you've probably seen this adorable
and also somewhat gross photo of twins born
in Ohio, who emerged from the womb holding
hands.
AWWWWWWW.
This is especially noteworthy because the
twins are monoamniotic - meaning they share
the same amniotic sac and placenta.
It's a rare occurrence, happening in around
1 in 10,000 births - and it's extremely risky,
because the twins have a high chance of becoming
entangled in the umbilical cords during pregnancy.
Thankfully, these two were born healthy and
happy - but it got me thinking, what are the
odds of having twins?
Turns out it's a lot higher now, than it was
even a few decades ago.
In 2010, twins accounted for about 1 in 30
births - and while that may seem extremely
high, keep in mind that fraternal twins - those
who don't share identical features - make
up well over two-thirds of that.
Even so, these numbers are continuing to rise.
The birth rate for twins has risen by 76%
over the past 30 years, and there are several
reasons why that might be.
Most of it, is due to a rise in fertility
treatments - which increases the odds of having
multiple births by around 20-40%.
Another factor, is the fact that women are
now waiting longer to have children.
As we get older, our bodies go through hormonal
changes - that cause us to release multiple
eggs at once.
So even though women over 35 are less likely
to get pregnant overall, they're also more
likely to have multiple births, in the event
that they do.
For women age 40, the odds of having twins
is around 7%, and at 45, that number goes
up to a whopping 17%.
There's also genetic factors that make us
more likely to have multiple births.
For example, if someone in your family has
given birth to twins, then you are also more
likely to have them.
And the same goes for your children.
The more pregnancies you've had - the more
likely you are to have twins.
And if you've already had a set of fraternal
twins, then you're much more likely to have
another pair sometime in the future.
Being a certain race can also predispose you.
For instance, African-Americans are more likely
to have twins than any other race, while Hispanic
and Asian people are the least likely.
Then there are things you would never even
consider to have an effect, like body type.
Studies have shown that twins are more common
in women who are taller and heavier, than
in women who are small or underweight.
Another study from 2003, shows that women
who take folic acid supplements during their
time of conception, increase their odds of
having twins by 40%.
And multiple reports conclude that women who
increase their dairy consumption before and
during conception - are up to 5x more likely
to have twins, perhaps due to the synthetic
growth hormones that are injected in cows.
Believe it or not, there is an entire subset
of women devoted to "twinning," which is the
practice of changing your diet and habits,
in order to increase your odds of having multiple
births.
And aside from all the medical complications
twins can bring - personally, the idea of
having two separate people growing inside
of me for 9 months - is kinda terrifying.
But I'm also not a mother, so the thought
of having children, in general, is kinda terrifying.
Can you tell I'm easily scared?
Anyway, I'm sure some of you out there watching
this, have given birth to twins - and if you
have, we'd love to hear about your experience.
Just leave your thoughts in the comments below,
and as always - thanks for watching!